DeSantis is adamantly opposed to the
position that most Republicans in
Washington have taken on Ukraine
DeSantis is not a neocon who knew quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests DeSantis rights securing our
borders addressing the crisis of
Readiness within our military achieving
energy security and Independence and
checking the economic cultural and
military power of the Chinese Communist
Party becoming further entangled in a
territorial dispute between Ukraine and
Russia is not one of them the U.S should
not provide assistance that could
require the deployment of American
troops or enable Ukraine to engage in
offensive operations Beyond its borders
the reason he read that one the way he
did is hey this guy is not a neocon he
doesn't want to get us in these crazy
Wars what I also liked about desantis's
commentary there it was the most
detailed